so a simple pendulum is just a mass
hanging from a string
and if you were to pull this mass
sometimes it's called a pendulum bob
if you were to pull it back and then let
go gravity would act as a restoring
force
and this mass would swing back and forth
over and over
and because this simple pendulum is a
simple harmonic oscillator
its motion its angle as a function of
time would be accurately described by a
sine or a cosine graph
so in other words if you were to pull
this back initially by 15 degrees
you might get a graph that looks
something like this now
every simple harmonic oscillator has a
characteristic period
of motion now the period of motion is
the time it takes
to complete one full cycle so the time
it takes to swing from here
all the way to there all the way back to
here would be one
full period and in this graph i've
written it as 0.5 seconds
but the period of every simple pendulum
is not going to be 0.5 seconds the
period of a simple pendulum
depends on the characteristics of that
pendulum and the environment that it's
in
so to derive this formula for the period
of a pendulum you would need calculus
so i'm just going to write it down give
you a quick tour and compare it
with the period formula for a mass on a
spring so the period of a pendulum is
going to be equal to
2 pi times the square root
of the ratio of the length of the
pendulum l
so the length of that string here the
length l
divided by g the gravitational
acceleration
of the planet that the pendulum is being
used on
now if you look at this and you've been
paying attention in physics you might be
like wait that looks really similar
to the formula for the period of a mass
on a spring so if you were to take a
mass on a spring
displace it 15 centimeters you'd get a
similar graph
and this would also have a
characteristic period of motion
and if you wrote down the period for a
mass on a spring it looks like this its
period
for a mass on a spring is also 2 pi so
that's identical
and it's also the square root of a ratio
but
instead of l over g for the mass on a
spring it's
m the mass of the block connected to the
spring divided by k
the spring constant of the spring so one
obvious similarity between these two
formulas is just their format they're
both a two pi
times a square root of a ratio but
another important similarity between
these that might not be evident
is that neither of these formulas depend
on the amplitude of the motion
so the period of a pendulum does not
depend on the amplitude of the motion
and the period of a mass on a spring
also does not depend on the amplitude of
the motion what i mean by that is if you
were to pull this pendulum back
instead of 15 degrees pull it back 20
degrees and let go
it would have farther to swing so its
motion might look something like this
and would get down farther and it would
get back up but it would take the exact
same amount of time
the period would not change if you
pulled this amplitude back farther
same goes with this mass on a spring
instead of pulling at 15 centimeters
let's say you pulled it 20 centimeters
again this would start up higher
it would get down lower but the time it
takes to complete one full cycle
would not vary as you vary this
amplitude and that might seem weird
you're like wait
don't these objects have farther to go
now that you pulled it back to a larger
amplitude that's true
they'll both have farther to travel but
they'll be going faster now
and faster motion over a bigger distance
is going to offset and the amplitude
does not affect the period
of the motion of a pendulum or of a mass
on a spring as for the differences
well the denominator here for the mass
on a spring depends on
k and that's the spring constant k and
that should make sense
more spring constant means you get more
restoring force the spring force is the
restoring force here
more restoring force means this mass is
going to be moving faster
that means it's going to take less time
to go through a full period
so dividing by a bigger number bigger
spring k
gives you less period that's also true
here but it's not k
the force that's the restoring force for
a pendulum isn't a spring it's the force
of gravity
so mg depends on the g so a bigger g
would give you a bigger restoring force
over here for the pendulum
that means the pendulum could be moving
faster moving faster means it's going to
take
less time to complete a full period so
dividing by a bigger g if you took this
pendulum to
the surface of jupiter or something
where the g is bigger
it would swing back and forth faster it
would take less time to complete it
because that restoring force is bigger
so even though these denominators are
different letters
they're arriving from the same source
they're both arriving because
the restoring force is larger when you
increase these denominators which
increases the speed of the object now
maybe the biggest difference here is
that the
numerator here for the mass on a spring
depends on mass
but nowhere is mass to be found in this
period of a pendulum the period of a
pendulum does not depend on the mass
this is kind of interesting so you know
really big heavy person gets on a swing
swings back and forth very light child
gets on the same swing
they will take the same amount of time
to complete a full cycle
the mass does not factor in here to the
period of a pendulum but it does
for the mass on a spring why is that
well
bigger mass on a spring gives you more
inertia in the system
if you have more inertia in the system
it's more sluggish to movement
it's going to go slower that means it's
going to take more
time to complete a full cycle now you
might think wait a minute
doesn't that hold true up here look if
we have a bigger mass
pendulum bob that should increase the
rotational inertia
and so that should make this take longer
it should be more sluggish to movement
should take longer to go through a full
period but look it
the restoring force is also for a
pendulum proportional to mass
so if you increase the mass of this
pendulum you do get more inertia but
you're getting more restoring force
because the restoring force is gravity
those completely offset mass does not
end up showing up into this pendulum
formula even though it does down here
so the spring force is not proportional
to mass spring force is kx
increasing the mass of this block on the
end
does not increase the spring restoring
force so this mass stays in the
numerator here but it does not affect
the period of a pendulum so why does
this l show up then why is it length of
the pendulum in the numerator
well the rotational inertia does get
increased when you increase the length
of a pendulum but increasing that length
does not increase the force of gravity
if you want to get technical rotational
inertia is proportional to length
squared but the torque would only be
proportional to length that's why only
one l shows up here
long story short if you increase the
length of a pendulum
you're going to increase the inertia of
that pendulum that's going to make it
take
longer to go through a full cycle this
is why i like going to the park and
finding the long swings
the longer the swing the longer it
actually takes the more time it actually
takes to swing back and forth
i think that's more fun than the little
short swings that go back and forth
really quick
so let's try a sample problem to see how
this period formula works let's say you
went to the
park you're 60 kilograms you're swinging
on a swing and your friend
pulls you back 20 degrees on a swing
that's a one meter in length
let's find the period of the motion so
in other words the time it takes to go
all the way to here
and then all the way back to there we
use the period formula
for a pendulum it's 2 pi
root l over g and so we would do
2 pi times the square root the length
here is the length of the string here so
one meter technically you'd be to
wherever your center of mass is but
we're going to assume
our center of mass is right here at the
end divided by
g well we're on earth i'm assuming so
9.8
meters per second squared if you solve
all that you get a period of about
two seconds exactly so this swing would
have a period
of about two seconds now notice we did
not use this 20 degrees
that's the amplitude this period does
not depend on the amplitude we also did
not use the fact that i was 60 kilograms
the period of a pendulum also does not
depend on the mass of the bob at the end
of the pendulum
we only use the length and if you're on
earth the denominator here is always
going to be 9.8
now one thing i should be clear about is
that a pendulum is technically not a
perfect
simple harmonic oscillator it's only
approximately a simple harmonic
oscillator so this formula here is only
approximately correct
but for small angles it's almost perfect
so at 20 degrees
this formula is only going to be off the
error is only going to be about one
percent
which isn't bad if you get this back to
like 70 degrees
even then the error is only around 10
percent
so this is a really really good
approximation if you're in small angles
like around 20 to 30 degrees
the bigger the angle gets though the
worse the approximation gets
for small angles most physicists just
treat a pendulum as if it's a perfect
simple harmonic oscillator as you get to
those higher angles though you got to be
careful
this can start deviating more
significantly from the actual value
so to recap the period of a pendulum
depends on the length of the pendulum
and the surface gravity of the planet
that you're on
it does not depend on the amplitude or
the mass of the pendulum
and the form it takes is very similar to
the period of a mass on a spring
where the numerator increases due to
increased inertia
and the denominator increases due to
increased restoring force